figure relève bonjour on est en direct
cet après midi ce lundi après midi pour
la fin d'un feuilleton la fin d'un
feuilleton qui dure depuis des mois
voire des années c'est le cas qu'ils
allaient mbappé qui a annoncé ce
week-end qu'il resterait au psg jusqu'en
2025 une décision qui a fait beaucoup de
bruit et il sera en conférence de presse
à partir de 15 heures avec le président
du psg pour en parler un peu avant je
suis avec sébastien ferra joaillier ce
sport au figaro bowler sébastien fallu
vincent salut à tous avec vous on va
décrypter un peu analysé cette décision
ce qui les tenants et les aboutissants
ce qui a pu faire pencher la balance
alors qu'effectivement il ya encore
quelques mois on n'était pas forcément
les plus comment dire on ne pensait pas
que ça allait se passer que quelques
appels est resté au psg non les
supporters parisiens n'étaient pas très
pas très optimiste ça c'est clair ça a
été tellement de situations quand même
ces derniers jours on s'attendait pas du
tout à ce que à ce que le bape est
prolongée ça fait des années maintenant
qu'on parle de lui au real madrid déjà
quand il était à monaco alors que ça
fait maintenant cinq ans qu'il est au pg
déjà avant on parlait de lui à montréal
c'est une énorme surprise de le voir
prolonger au psg ça a été tout un
retournement de situation qu'on va
essayer un petit peu d'analysé de
décortiquer aujourd'hui bien sûr et
surtout vous n'hésitez pas à poser vos
questions dans le chat de youtube de
twitch de notre site le figaro on
essaiera d'y répondre du mieux qu'on
peut cette décision une surprise on l'a
dit d'où elle vient et ce qu'on sait
d'où vient un peu ce retournement il y
avait beaucoup d'incertitude sur mbappé
sur l'idée qu'il prolonge au psg pour
avant tout pour des raisons sportives
alors bien sûr il ya toujours l'aspect
financier même si à ce niveau là on peut
dire tgi real madrid est une sorte de
club à ces riches qui peuvent proposer
des choses très avantageuses à ce moment
là c'était plus a priori l'aspect
sportif qui pouvait poser problème on
voyait le psg qui courent toujours
apprécié cette ligue des champions qui a
multiplié les échecs ces dernières
années en huitièmes de finale alors
certes il ya une finale dans l'eau un
moment donné mais le plus souvent ça
s'arrête en huitièmes et ça a été encore
le cas cette année contre le real madrid
un moment qu'on a vu un petit peu comme
le couperet définitif pour le pour le
départ de me taper au real
maintenant c'est passé pas arrivé et on
voit qu'en fait il ya aussi de gros
changements sportifs qui sont
actuellement en train de se dérouler au
psg avec notamment le changement à la
direction sportive oui on parlera de
tous ces sujets là la symbolique
effectivement du match contre le real
alors que je vous rappelle que dans 5
minutes qu'ils allaient bape est
lui-même s'exprimera et pourra donner
son avis même si qu'ils allaient maps et
on connaît on est sur la communication
très maîtrisée oui très maîtrisée et en
même temps assez assez franche je me
rappelle qu'en octobre lorsqu'il avait
lorsqu'il avait sa première vraie sortie
médiatique sur sur le sujet il avait
reconnu qu'il avait voulu partir pendant
l'été et il avait notamment répondu avec
beaucoup de franchise aux questions
qu'on lui avait posé notamment sur
nasser al-khelaifi qui avait dit je me
souviens qu'il ya ne partira jamais
libre et battait ont bien fait rigoler
avait dit quand j'ai entendu ça j'ai
failli m'étouffer je me suis dit mais
qu'est ce qui va se passer en fait il
avait été assez assez cash sur sur le
sujet et encore on l'a vu lorsqu'il a
annoncé sa prolongation il a fait un
petit communiqué sur l'airé sur les
réseaux sociaux où il a il a notamment
dit qu'il serait le premier supporters
du real en finale de ligue des champions
ce samedi et qu' il avait utilisé une
formule du genre leur déception est à la
hauteur de mes espérances pour jouer
pour ce club de mon amour pour ce club
qu'il n'a qui n'a jamais caché oui parce
que on rappelle qu'un mot si elle bat p
va aussi permettre ça va lui permettre
de rentrer dans la légende en tant que
parisien et ne pas rentrer on avait ça
comme argument du côté du psg au real de
madrid il rejoignait une grande
institution alors que là on construit
autour d'un joueur oui c'est ça allait
un peu cette idée de sylla au real
madrid il serait finalement une légende
parmi tant d'autres dans l'histoire du
real comme comme il y en a énormément
aujourd'hui dans ce club qui est
sûrement le plus grand club au monde
alors qu'au psg il ya peut-être un peu
plus une histoire à écrire avec un club
qui court depuis toujours après après
cette fameuse ligue des champions qui
rêvent d'atteindre d'atteindre ce rêve
on a parfois dit que ma paix pourra
peut-être peut-être être le le francisco
totti du psg pour comparer avec totti
qui a fait toute sa carrière à l'as rome
qui a une légende absolue
brad et en plus parce qu'il a commencé à
monaco fortement et je pense que c'est
une comparaison comme bp ne doit pas
beaucoup apprécié parce que totti
malheureusement c'est un grand vainqueur
il n'a jamais gagné la ligue des
champions il n'a pas un grand palmarès
alors que le pape et c'est clairement
pas c'est clairement pas son billet son
idée c'est justement de tirer pg vers le
haut et de l'installer comme l'un des
plus grands clubs au monde là mais plus
grands clubs européens et que ça parle
vraiment de lui avant tout et en plus de
ça l'an dernier lionel messi arrive il
ya quelques années c'était neymar
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment mba paix qui
a pris le pouvoir finalement sur sur
cette équipe totalement map est la
pierre angulaire du psg et ça c'est pas
moi qui le dis là je reprends un terme
de nasser al-khelaifi et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que c'est exactement
le terme qu'il avait employé lorsque
neymar était arrivé au psg en étant que
bas b et c le bape est lui même qui l'a
dit il encore une fois je vais le site
et il avait dit qu'il arrivait au départ
pour aider neymar ce sont les termes de
clients mbappé est aujourd'hui
clairement le rapport de force s'est
totalement inversée aujourd'hui la star
au psg semba baisser le joueur numéro un
c'est avec lui qu'on construit le projet
alors je suis pas fan de l'idée on
construit autour de lui parce que je
pense qu'au foot on est sur un sport
quand même plus collectif que d'autres
sports déjà collectif mais il y avoir
une dimension collective encore plus
fort que je pense donc pas toujours
penser à est ce que ce joueur est une
bague est compatible pas toujours
fonctionné comme ça mais effectivement
avant tout aujourd'hui lui c'est lui la
star du psg et on part on part avant
tout à la guerre des clans surtout que
le psg qui a fait venir le nail messi
avait des années marc on a vu que je
joue avec ses cesser ces trois joueurs
ça comporte quand même quelques petites
faiblesses même s'ils se sont un peu de
génie du foot chacun mais ça ça comporte
comme des faiblesses voilà qu'il suffit
pas juste de les mettre sur un terrain
et que ça va marcher comme par magie en
ligue des champions et qui que ça
passera avec ça et ça ira au bout on l'a
vu c'est déjà compliqué pour rayonner le
messie de lancer sa saison parce qu'il
ya eu des petits pépins physiques et une
préparation physique qui a été assez
tronquée ensuite j'ai eu des blessures
pour neymar sont trois joueurs qui n'ont
pas joué tant de matches que ça
lorsqu'on est arrivé en février mars aux
grandes échéances de de ligue des
champions donc forcément ça ça a été
compliqué on a un entraîneur en plus
mauricio pochettino qui n'avait
absolument pas la main sur son équipe on
avait beaucoup de mal à avoir une pâte
peau cetin on a souvent vu ce fameux 7 +
3 c'est à dire qu'on avait dix joueurs
de champ on avait sept joueurs plus les
3 2 qu'ils se débrouillent tout seuls
qui ne défendrait pas qui était
complètement séparées et parfois c'était
vraiment caricatural donc on a vu que ça
ne suffisait pas et c'est pour ça aussi
peut-être comme pape et reste au psg
parce qu'il semble qu'il va y avoir de
grands changements sportif au sein du
club lui même peut être un petit peu à
pulse et on en reparlera et que
maintenant le psg pourra vraiment
ressemblé à une équipe avec toujours ces
start et ça a déjà commencé d'ailleurs
ce week-end puisque c'est leonardo qui
est qui est parti c'est ce alors je sais
pas si j'ai eu un communiqué officiel du
psg pour pour vraiment de l'annoncé ces
actes et lolo nardo va quitter le psg ne
sera plus le directeur sportif il est
remplacé par luis campos un directeur
sportif portugais qui a déjà bien
travaillé en france et bien travaillé au
sens vraiment en qualitatif à l'as
monaco le titre de lille d'ailleurs
exactement monaco peut-être que mba
pleurs à des bons souvenirs voilà il en
a sûrement des bons souvenirs et c'est
peut-être pas un hasard si mbappè
prolonge et que louise campos arrivera
en même temps là on n'est même pas sûr
une promesse on est sur quelque chose d'
acte et je pense clairement parce que ma
paie le voulez parce que le bape et a
donné son feu vert en gros on peut
imaginer que ce sera maintenant la même
chose avec l'entraîneur avec pas mal de
joueurs de l'effectif comme la paix sera
assez consultés c'est assez normal
quelque part de consulter ses stars je
pense que ça serait un petit peu dans
tous les grands clubs d'avoir un petit
peu leur avis a plus plus ou moins après
selon les joueurs selon les clubs selon
la façon de gérer des joueurs en tout
cas maintenant sûr qu'il aime bab et on
est clairement sur un joueur qui prend
énormément de place dans le pouvoir
sportif du psg on a eu des échos de
médias souvent venus d'espagne qui
disait que c'était ma pelle et devenir
le directeur sportif de 2 du psg tout ça
c'est pas vraiment sérieux oui c'est
exagéré c'est largement exagéré il idée
justement c'est là dans une hiérarchie
claire d'avoir
pour schématiser un petit peu un
directeur sportif qui qui fait le
directeur sportif un président qui
préside un joueur qui joue maintenant
c'est pas juste ce n'est pas juste
verticale c'est aussi un petit peu
horizontale battait va forcément avoir
son poids dans beaucoup de décisions il
va être beaucoup consulté
je pense qu'on s'est en tout cas le sens
d un fossé clairement que si le bape ait
accepté de prolonger c'est aussi parce
qu'il ya une certaine notion pouvoir qui
lui accorder et qu'il sent que il va
pouvoir vraiment influencer le projet de
ce club c'est quelque chose de presque
inédit dans football à ce niveau là en
tout cas je sais pas si on a vu beaucoup
de grands joueurs influent autant une
grande équipe avoir autant poids bape et
n'est pas le directeur sportif du psg
mais il va avoir une influence je pense
sans précédent sur sur l'aspect sportif
du club surtout à un âge aussi jeune
finalement 23 ans est ce qu'il ya des
précédents comme ça de deux clubs qui
pourraient à peu tout m pour leurs
joueurs je suis pas sûr c'est pas c'est
toujours un petit peu opaque bien sûr on
a vu un peu de temps justement le cas
lionel messi le barça qui était
absolument tout pour le garder mais qui
a dû se résoudre à un moment donné il
n'avait pas l'argent ils n'ont pas pu
ils n'ont pas pu le garder mais on avait
ce côté un joueur quitte est passé
complètement son club tout dépend des
lui que tout était orientée selon lui
maintenant des présidents comme bab et
franchement je pense qu'il ya pas
beaucoup alors qu'on a les premières
images de la de la salle de conférence
de presse voilà qu'ils auront merci à
ariane v qui requis étant régie et qui
va nous montrer ces images voilà donc ça
ce sont ce sont des images actuellement
du
excusez-moi de la salle de conférence de
presse c'est prévu pour 15h on est
souvent un petit peu en retard dans ces
événements là ça devrait durer une
vingtaine de minutes c'est ça oui alors
on parle de 20 entre 20 et 40 minutes ça
va dépendre peut-être aussi un petit peu
des questions qui seront posées un bape
ait un intérêt qualifie on verra comment
comment ça va durer on imagine qu'au
début ailleurs un petit peu un discours
d'intronisation pour représenter toute
cette histoire présenté comment c'est
arrivé que que quelqu'un les filles va
dire je te réponds tu en voilà ma télé
je suis très content c'était trop
souffler un petit peu alors discours
qu'ils ont déjà tenu au parc des princes
samedi ou même dans divers communiqué
maintenant ce qui sera intéressant c'est
de voir aussi comment ils vont me
répondre un petit peu aux questions
qu'on va leur poser effectivement et ce
qu'on suivra on n'a pas encore parlé de
l'aspect financier parce que quand même
pour garder un joueur quand même map et
il faut mettre les moyens sont à table
on sait que le kata à ces moyens là est
ce que on s'est un peu ce qui a été mis
sur la table paul va pour lever restait
alors est ce conseil ne s'est pas
vraiment parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'informations et parce que tout ça est
très opaque on sera peut-être vraiment
jamais
maintenant ce qui a l'air de sortir
c'est que les deux offres et c'est la
mère de maps et je crois qu'ils disaient
elle disait que les deux clés deux
offres du psg et du real était assez
semblables sans peut croire on peut
imaginer qu'il n'y a pas non plus le psg
n'a pas dit combien offre l'horaire nous
offre le double qu on est sur des sur
les offres assez similaires et que ça
serait plus sur l'aspect peut-être
sportif de comment convaincre le joueur
de venir ici que l'avenir doit s'écrire
ici maintenant sur sur les montants
on évoque entre 30 et 50 millions
d'euros annuels après ça dépend de la
durée du contrat ça peut être je crois
qu'on parlait de 30 millions d'euros
annuels sur cinq ans au real madrid est
de 50 millions annuels sur trois ans au
psg donc en gros c'est la même somme au
final mais il l'a gagnerait beaucoup
plus vite au psg après ce qui se dit
aussi c'est que le réal en revanche on
aurait une prime à la signature plus
élevé donc quelque part ça
contrebalancerait un petit peu et aussi
la question des droits d'image qui est
un peu dans la balance ça l'aidera à
nivelles et qu'on peut expliquer un peu
comment comment ça marche sans rentrer
dans les détails bien donner le nom mais
pour quelqu'un comme canet 2 maps et
c'est très important oui c'est très
important parce qu'en fait les droits à
l'image c'est donc il est les revenus
liés aux sponsors aux sponsors du club
ou sponsors personnels du joueur essayez
de savoir dans quelle mesure ces revenus
reviendront directement aux joueurs ce
sont des revenus énormes je crois que
messi au barça sur la fin ça
représentait presque 15% de ce qu'il
gagne et ça se mesure en dizaines de
millions d'euros pour un joueur comme
bape et surtout pour l'avenir ça va être
extrêmement important il ya aussi la
question même lié aux droits d'image et
notamment l'équipe de france 2 maps et
qui vole un peu de contrôler son image
qui se disaient nos sponsors moi je
n'aime pas trop j'aime pas trop les
valeurs que ça véhicule ça me parle pas
trop j'ai pas trop envie de m'afficher
avec ça tout ça donc les droits d'image
oui c'est une énorme question surtout
pour ma paie sa rarement été je pense au
temps où tant une question ça l'a déjà
été pour d'autres joueurs notamment
paolo dibala lorsqu'on parlait d'un
départ de la juventus donc la paix c'est
une grosse question et ces questions
avec de très grosses ou en l'occurrence
alors que qu'il allait m'achever et
nacéra et fit le président du psg arrive
on va laisser passer cette conférence de
presse et on reviendra tout à l'heure
pour décrypter un peu tout ce qui a été
dit on écoutera bien évidemment ce
qu'ils vont dire et surtout ce qu'ils
vont répondre aux questions des
journalistes
bonjour à tous bonjour à tout le paris
saint-germain très heureux de vous
accueillir aujourd'hui on court des
princes pour la conférence de presse du
président du paris saint-germain nasser
al-khelaifi et le killian maps et d'ici
quelques instants vous pourrez vos
questions sur
la prolongation de clients aiment bape
et jusqu'en 2025
nous vous demanderons de lever la main
d'attendre les micros vous parviennent
de donner le nom du média que vous
représentez et votre nom avant de poser
vos questions mais avant ça je laisse la
parole aux présidents du paris saint
germain monsieur nacelle après les
filles c'est toujours à tout à tous
aujourd'hui c'est un grand jour pour
l'histoire du val saint germain ca
pour nous c'est important aussi en
france monde entier
qu'ils y allaient rester bas et
sincèrement toi saison prochaine je
pense est très important pour nous pour
les gars pour la france
ces choix est une signe très fort
nous gardons les meilleurs joueurs
demandent
quel yens
c'est un rêve ça objectif toujours pour
gagner et gagner comme la clape font
gagner un de nos objectifs aussi avec le
président de liga avec thomas président
de la hat ou la clape
ont via un des meilleurs championnats au
monde entier
elle reste ici parce que barry le mais
les meilleures conditions pour réaliser
nos objectifs sportifs
comme jeudi gagner et gagner et gagner
je vous remercie sa famille
qui croît de notre projet était très
important pour moi personnellement je
vous remercie aussi tous les équipes de
volley sincèrement qu'ils travaillaient
de cette prolongation
si un étapes vont continuer notre
objectif notre projet notre grand soir
avec qu'il ya
tellement de lancer les premiers jours
on est venu ici pour gagner
pour m aussi les grands cris l'espoir
les grands histoire de bâle et saint
germain merci
on va passer la phase de questions
réponses allez-y
bonjour à tous les deux bons jours qui
viennent nicolas georgereau rtl ici je
voulais savoir ce qu'ont ressenti
personnel si ces dernières semaines
derniers mois ça a été éprouvant par
moments il ya encore récemment qu'on
après le match face à lorient face à
saint-etienne qui est venu répondre à
nos questions avec ton d'aisance et à
faciliter habituel mais je voulais
savoir si ça a été éprouvant par moments
bonjour à tous
non c'est vrai que celle avantage c'est
qu'il y avait une saison donc il y avait
des objectifs auxquels on devait
répondre auquel on était amené à
répondre aussi on a réussi à gagner le
titre mais mais bien sûr que bien sûr
que ça plaise pas ce que c'était une
décision difficile mais j'ai toujours
voulu me réfugier dans mon football
parce que c'est c'est là où je suis bon
c'est ce que je sais faire et après je
savais que on allait être amené à parler
de ça je voulais prendre le temps aussi
de de faire le meilleur choix possible
mon choix et j'avais pas de problème
particulier avec la pression parce que
je l'est depuis que j'ai j'ai 14 ans
donc il n'y a pas de problème avec ça
le micro le micro le
bonjour du bodoland journal l'équipe à
quel point vous avez donné les pleins
pouvoirs sportifs aa quillanais mbappé
on sait que le projet sportif est
important dans la discussion vous avez
eu depuis maintenant plusieurs mois à
quel point il va avoir un droit de
regard sur le recrutement sur la
nomination de l'organigramme merci
très honnête avec vous
le premier jour je rencontrais sa
famille acadienne on parle de faute aux
sportifs
même qu'on a acheté à kelly à monaco ça
veut dire que ce que j'aime chez kélian
c'est sportif football
qu'est-ce qui les iem par les faits m
faire c'est la vérité si vous dire qu'en
volvo mais c'est la vérité six sportifs
nous convient ici qu'on a un effet notre
investissement de paris saint germain
parce qu'on à paris en france non
d'éclat pour grandir on fait quelque
chose aussi gagné aucun trophée on a
gagné pas mal mais encore on vous gagnez
plus vous gagnez plus
championnat aussi champion bien sûr
c'est clair on ce n'est
même la même
voix de même
rue pour gagner le même but sportif
le projet sportif je pense l'été le plus
important pour kilian ou safari ici je
peux intervenir même si la question
n'est pas pour moi
je reste quand même un joueur de foot il
emporte je suis entré dans un collectif
peu importe même si bien sûr il ya des
il ya des statuts dans une équipe mais
je reste quand même un joueur de foot et
j'irai pas au delà de cette fonction
bien sûr si on est amené à parler
football j'aime le football à tout le
monde connaît ma passion j'aime discuter
foot parler foot mais j'irai jamais au
delà de ma fonction de joueurs de foot
jean yanne le rectorat un petit sport
juste d'expliquer pourquoi le paris
saint germain il ya un an vous voulez
partir pour rejoindre le real madrid
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en un an pour
que finalement vous décidé de prolonger
au psg oui bien sûr tout le monde sait
que l'année dernière je voulais partir
et javel intime conviction que c'était
là la meilleure décision possible à ceux
à ce moment là
maintenant il ya les années elles se
suivent mais ne se ressemblent pas
aujourd'hui il y avait un contexte qui
était différent un contexte sportif un
contexte aussi un contexte privé un
contexte aussi que j'étais libre et qu'
en tant que français et tout le monde
mon importance que je sais dans le pays
c'est un pays dans lequel je vais vivre
dans lequel je vais vieillir je vais
revenir ici après ma carrière donc
quitté mon pays comme ça voilà par la
petite porte non pas ce que je serais
parti comme un grand joueur mais il ya
ce côté aussi sentimental de se dire que
c'est mon pays et aussi le projet a
changé le bleu
le club a envie de changer pas mal de
choses sur le plan sportif et donc ça
m'a donné vraiment cette envie de
continuer parce que je pense que mon
histoire n est pas fini ici que ce soit
sur le plan collectif et même sur le
plan individuel je pense que mon history
si elle n'est pas terminée et je pense
que j'ai des beaux chapitres encore à
écrire et ses
bons jours qui viennent alexis longtemps
de la fp quel jour avez-vous pris votre
décision
et est ce que vous pouvez un peu nous
décrire votre annonce aux coéquipiers
mais aussi au real madrid aussi merci
j'ai pris ma décision la semaine
dernière à cette armée nationale m je
n'ai pas annoncé à mes coéquipiers parce
que le club voulait pas voulait il
voulait garder ça secret de voulais
vraiment que ce soit une surprise pour
tout le monde même si c'est pas beaucoup
de surprises vous étiez pas mal
renseigné à ce que je voulais mais mais
après j'ai pris la décision en avant
avant de l'annoncer au paris
saint-germain d'appeler à d'appeler le
président florentino perez parce que
voilà j'ai beaucoup de respect pour lui
et son club parce qu'ils ont ils ont les
ont tous bien fait pour moi ils ont ils
ont essayé de me rendre le plus heureux
possible de faciliter mon arrivée pour
ça je le remercie et je pense qu'en
temps en temps comme respectueux et je
pense que c'est dans mon devoir de la de
lui parler personnellement et voilà
comme nos liens et et était très proche
donc je pense que c'était la meilleure
chose à faire et après on a réussi à
terminer les contours du contrat et
ensuite on l'a on là ne sont pas que des
princes et les joueurs l'ont appris à la
télévision dans le vestiaire
bonjour killian bertrand latour la
chaîne équipe après avoir dit non au
real madrid en 2017 tu n'as pas pu y
aller en 2021 est ce qu'on choisit sans
le psg cette année au détriment des
malades est ce que tu penses avoir dit
adieu à son rêve d'enfant ou d'être sur
les envies d'ailleurs jours
vous savez dans le football il ya une
vérité c'est que j'ai appris à vraiment
regarder vraiment juste devant moi par
regarder trop loin parce que voilà il ya
un an en arrière je pensais même pas
être ici devant ou
voilà donc aujourd'hui je signe ce
nouveau contrat voilà j'ai je pense
avoir une décision personnelle a appris
le le meilleur choix pour moi je regarde
pas de vent je suis vraiment concentré
sur ce nouveau contrat m'investir
pleinement sur
sur ce nouveau projet sur cette nouvelle
ère est ce qui se passera dans le futur
je sais pas si je peux tu s'il peut me
permettre tu sais pas où tu seras dans
un 1 3 en moi je sais pas peut-être
aussi mais moi je ne sais pas
qu'il y a bonjour dans ses bons jours ci
à gonnehem étaient bonnes annonces du
président abbas a déposé une france est
désolé pour le niveau de conseil s'est
déjà vu j'imagine que pendant les
dernières mois peut-être les dernières
semaines
les deux côtés sj real madrid on
essayait de vous persuader de vous
convaincre
dans les rues quelques projette
quelle était l'importance j'imagine que
vous aviez aussi beaucoup décrire son
pour rester ici quelle est l importance
les rôles des neymar hymne et si dans
ton choix
quelle importance de ta volonté de
réussir avec les trios au lieu de partir
après juste une saison jouent ensemble
a déjà je pense que
que ce soit le paris saint germain je
suis aujourd'hui et le real madrid ce
sont des clubs qui ont pas besoin de
convaincre ils n'ont pas besoin de
convaincre des joueurs cdd grand club je
pense que pour toujours ce doit être un
honneur de venir jouer pour l'un l'un de
ces deux clubs maintenant pour pour
parler de démarrer mais si c'est sûr que
jouer avec des grands joueurs c'est tout
ce que j'ai toujours voulu voilà on a
une première année difficile parce qu'on
a eu on a eu mais city qui venait
d'arriver mais marquis qui s'est blessé
malheureusement il n'a pas pu enchaîner
les performances mais je pense que la
qualité de ces deux joueurs elle est
plus elle est plus à prouver après je
pense qu'on a on en a parlé un peu mais
pas beaucoup parce que comme il disait
il me dit toujours que c'était un choix
personnel et que quelle que soit ma
décision et je la respecterai et pour ça
je les remercie
merci aux gens qu'il ya un bon jean
lasserre jean françois perez europe 1 il
ya trois ans au gala de l'unef paix si
je me suis un bien vous aviez dit
j'aimerais avoir plus de responsabilités
aux parisiens jardins mais ce rire dans
le centre de ce projet aujourd'hui vous
avez tenu à compléter la réponse à une
question qu'on à serra a parlé en disant
je suis avant tout un joueur de football
il ne faut pas l'oublier ses
responsabilités en question quel
peuvent-elles être désormais est ce que
vous voulez par exemple être le
capitaine du paris saint germain est ce
que vous l'avez demandé qu'est ce que ça
peut être d'autre merci beaucoup
déjà pour rebondir à la première partie
de la question j'ai toujours j'ai
toujours répété après coup que c'était
c'était une erreur ce que j'avais ce que
j'avais dit d'où l'endroit le timing et
la forme peut-être que le fonds et des
été bon mais la forme l'endroit et le
timing n'était pas bon
maintenant je pense ça va après avoir un
peu plus de maturité que les
responsabilités ça s'acquiert sur le
terrain et je pense c'est ce que j'ai
fait après j'ai réussi à gagner le
respect de mes coéquipiers de mes
adversaires sur le terrain et je pense
que c'est de là que je vais garder le
respect après bien sûr s'investir dans
un projet je pense que c'est on n'a pas
besoin d'avoir des responsabilités pour
s'investir dans un projet est
aujourd'hui pour répondre au capitanat
je pense qu'il ya il ya déjà un
capitaine voilà c'est un joueur
important en plus de notre projet j'ai
pas envie de devenir lui couper la tête
comme ça je pense que c'est important
c'est quelqu'un qui qui est important
dans le vestiaire un joueur important et
émérite il mérite son brassard il a
attendu c'est pas c'est pas une priorité
pour moi j'ai pas besoin d'être
capitaine pour donner mon point de vue
et et montrer l'exemple sur le terrain
la dynamique a
capté et syfy août vise à capter notre
team un adage dit maria et waddan di
maria même for you et garder six noms de
la swan
l'espagnol
leader
to talk about dit maria
clara pieter willem
en été c'est de rester debout la
république espagnole je pense que c'est
une question surtout pour le président
comme vous savez les patrons de la liga
espagnole nam n'a pas très bien pris et
les décisions des clients de rester il
dit que le psg c'est un club qui fait
des qui trichent sur ses comptes ce qui
ne respecte par l'ailé fair-play
financière qu'est ce que vous répondre
et je
pense un autre président de l'ec assez
dense et la preuve c'est pas la note d
vous dire c'est
je pense peut-être lé père légal est
bien mieux que la liga tarder si bon de
choses pendant 1 pour nous c'est
vraiment quelque chose on l'apprécié
beaucoup j'ai prié toujours la pause
était positif pour nos conclat comment
un jour les gars quand vous savez
ingérence de la liga c'est pas qu'on
était à trois encadrants
tous les respecte pour la toux la clape
tout la chaîne bénin extérieur mais nous
on respecte aussi la spéculation qui
respecte c'est très important au moi je
veux pas parler de tout vous dire parce
que c'est pas mon business nous on
grince trait sur notre club notre
championnat notre meilleur joueur au
monde
si la plus important pour moi
aujourd'hui
c'est le prêt on a mis un joueur demande
avec nouveau trois ans
après des choses qui parle qui dit
c'est pas un problème je n'écoute pas ça
tout ça vraiment un écran serait dans
notre projet merci
bonjour à tous les deux marques mais
chinois goal.com vous tout au long de
cette année de négociations on a
beaucoup parlé de demandes de garanties
sportives vous venez d'évoquer des
changements sportif ma question c'est
d'ailleurs s'adresse à vous deux quelles
sont ces changements et ces garanties
sportives que vous aviez demandé aux
autres quand je réponds mais je pense
comme l'a déclaré keller les joueurs
importants joueurs meilleurs joueurs au
monde tu vois on sait les joueurs nous
comme cloud en deux sites qu'est-ce
qu'on peut qu'est ce qu'on va faire
c'est bien sûr le
projet sportif c'est important pour
toute la classe tous les joueurs c'est
pas pour qu'il ya seulement moi je veux
pas vous concentrer sur qu'il y en ait
choisi les faits ça c'est pas vrai
qu'elles viennent jamais les demander
quelque chose qu'est ce que les voeux
jets d'objets dit comme je dire mon
disque sûrs niveau gagné à gagner gagner
comme nous c'est si bonne chose nous on
veut vraiment investi dongeois vous
gagnez avec nous si je ne veux pas
gagner on veut pas cette joie c'est le
blues man city magnifique on a vraiment
quelqu un magnifique joueur comme joueur
comme personne comme image pour la
france je pense une très bonne nouvelle
pour france moi j'ai pas attendu au
cutter une caution de positive on garde
la mer joueur en moins de france en
championnat une autre chambre et là je
pense vous dire dans la soul est
normalement très content de cette
nouvelle c'est pas on cherche pas de
problème je pense on est très heureux
moi je sais c'est pas vous tout le monde
mais quelques-unes à l'aise mais
peut-être extérieur douce - des plus
importants pour moi on a gardé le
meilleur joueur du monde on vous gardez
vous gagné qu'est ce que les volumes de
fautes de gagner c'est important pour
notre projet aussi tout le monde à la
semaine dernière on a perdu killian
kiely à dessiner d'autres clubs on a des
débats infinis n'étaient pas sûrs vers
l'ip
c'est la vérité mais toujours je crois
de clients de sa famille parce que je
sais on a construit quelque chose très
fort entre nous c'est pas c'est quelque
chose dont le projet de prévisions sur
le compte et sa famille auxquels jan
jambon cela quelque chose très très
forte c'est peut-être vous comprends pas
mais je pensais avec le futur on comprit
plus si positif pour le club pour les
championnats pour la france et les
français les parisiens et je les aime
trop son et rencontrer des amis aussi
trop cinq là je vous fais tout pour
l'éclat
mais quand ils perdent que nous ne dort
pas et s malade pour quelques jours de
semaine ça on joue comme ça notre joueur
je veux vraiment pas être fighter merci
on va prendre deux dernières questions
bonjour bonjour par blogolo d'union la
marque un tournant pour les médias
bienvenue merci
pour lasaire sais c'est possible
j'imagine qu'il y aura des chiffres
officiels mais si les contrats plus
importants de l'upg ça si ça veut dire
j'imagine que haut niveau
d'investissement c'est aussi important
et pourquoi autant de l'investissement
en france
et pour qu'il y aille et vous savez ça
me gênait les madridistas centre dessus
si vous savez à un message propos de
supporteurs du real merci
non si j'ai un si j'ai un message déjà
c'est de les remercier parce que j'ai
jamais porté le maillot du real madrid
si je les portais à 14 en une semaine
mais mais ils m'ont toujours toujours
acceptés comme l'un des leurs et pour ça
il faut il faut être reconnaissant il
faut savoir être reconnaissant donc je
veux juste déjà les remercier je
comprends je comprends la déception mais
j'espère qu'ils comprendront le fait que
j'ai choisie et j'ai choisi de rester
dans mon pays parce que voilà
aujourd'hui il ya une vérité c'est que
je suis français et comme j'ai dit comme
j'ai dis en tant que français j'ai envie
de continuer encore un peu essayé de
mener la france vers les sommets et
d'essayer de tirer ce championnat et
était ce club
regarde jamais on a annoncé des chiffres
tout ça jamais pas pour qu'il y ait un
bar et pour les autres on vous fera
jamais va faire ça mais je vais vous
dire une chose ce n'était pas
l'important de l'investissement de la
l'argent qu'on veut me dire en espagne
c'est pas le plus important pour qu'il y
ait la plus importante et
sportif le projet sportif c'est le plus
important vous gagner surtout après
l'argent je pense hélas l'autre club
dont votre pied le pot payer plus que
nous je veux dire du combat mais je
pense que c'était un choix sportif pas
de l'argent c'est ça je veux dire je
répète plus de vingt fois
pendant
en france parce qu'on est en france
français lemaire joueur au monde où la
meule éclats
c'est facile pour revendus
merci dernière question bonjour qui
viennent si ton laurent sport business
club en quoi l'importance de ton droit à
l'image sur les contrats de sponsoring
parce que ça lui l'important c'est
important dans cette prolongation de
contrat et plus globalement ta position
ton regard sur le sponsoring sportif et
l'utilisation de son image pour les
marques et deuxième question sera pour
nasser qu'en est-il de jorge campos
aujourd'hui louise composent partance
jorge campos
[Musique]
non moi c'est ce qui est drôle je sais
pas si c'est drôle pour vous aussi c'est
qu'avant ce rassemblement dès mars je
crois que personne a fait ne serait-ce
qu'un article même pas une brève sur les
droits à l'image il a fallu qu'il se
passe ce truc pour qu'il y est pas mal
de trucs où il veut pas faire ça il veut
pas faire s'il a dit ça il veut pas ça
les droits à l'image ça bloque en avril
alors que pour être honnête on a parlé
des mois de sportifs des heures d'imagés
des mines et d'argent ça a duré cinq
minutes c'était très rapide aucun
problème et je suis ce petit quiproquo
en sélection mais qu'on va qu'on va
régler très vite parce que leur la hyène
compétition qui arrive et on va pas se
créer des problèmes pour rien là on a un
pays à faire gagner et mais après je
pense que pour parler de ces gestions
sponsoring le football il a changé je
pense que vous le savez mieux que moi je
pense que la plupart des gens ici ils
sont dans le monde du foot plus
longtemps que moi le monde du football
il a changé il a une nouvelle vague qui
arrive et je pense que c'est juste
donner un droit de regard sur ce que sur
sur notre nom à quoi il est associé je
demande pas je demande pas grand chose
c'est juste que j'ai une carrière et
j'ai envie de gérer ma carrière comme je
l'entends com
comme ça me correspond avec les valeurs
que je veux brawn et je veux pas je pas
révolutionner le football j'y arriverai
pas et c'est pas mon objectif c'est pas
mon combat je pense que j'ai déjà pas
mal de soucis à me faire en gérant ma
carrière je veux pas non plus voilà
toujours chercher les problèmes mais je
pense que c'est quelque chose de simple
mais comme j'ai dit à van avant ce mois
de mars il n'y avait pas un article et
après tout le monde savait où il veut
pas faire s'il veut pas faire ça il a un
problème avec lui il veut plus de primes
que les autres joueurs de l'équipe de
france le président a parlé aussi l'un
j'ai entendu oui j'ai entendu et mais il
n'y a pas de problème on va régler ce
problème rapidement et avec intelligence
et respect je vais vous dire une chose
ou mois sur ce sujet ici c'est très
important qu'ils viennent avec nos 5 ans
jouer avec nous toujours respecte tous
les partenariats se pensent les images
même deux laits sa famille hier on a
parlé de choses qu'on a cédé contrat
mais qu'il y avait là un pied on a
instauré de paris saint germain sa
famille lui propose le départ nous
prouvera que propose beaucoup en effet
pas quelque chose pour s'éclater bassin
contrat n'est pas pour l'argent pour
rien désolé je veux dire ça parce que
c'est très honnête il a fait plus que
don contrat de quelque chose si vous
respecte les joueurs respectent
nullement jouvence si les mentalités je
pense de clients vraiment respectueux si
quelqu'un veut respecte les deux taux
jamais eu un seul mort dont deux par
balles aux cinq ans
si vous recrutez un problème avec
l'embrayage responsable j'aime j'ai pas
je défends ici qu'elle aime parce que
vraiment grand professionnel et fait
tout pour la capte plus qu'est ce
qu'elle a fait avec tous la charité tout
ça vous connais aussi ça c'est pas dans
le contrat mais l'a fait avec 5 à la
valeur de lui sa famille suivant ce
quelque chose moi j'ai proches vous
savez monsieur je connais deux les jeux
c'est l'impasse je parle de ça mais
c'est la vérité là un grand valeur de ça
aussi
le quotient de dure jusqu'en bosse
je bosse je connais pas ce qu'ils y
compose tout mais je pense être parce
qu'en france on vocalia les mérites moi
je promis c'est une scène avec eliane
usine avec nouveaux joueurs aussi parce
que vraiment les mérites sur l'opération
les mérites hersant piller qu'est ce
qu'elle a fait
qui mieux consignes avec lui à cinq ans
parce que la vie est ainsi plus fort le
pour tout le monde sur bronze du mérite
vraiment tout la crevette pour ça je
pense honnêtement avec sa famille on
vaut je sais jamais avoir été loué les
mêmes on va vraiment gagné beaucoup de
trophées ensemble parce qu'on est la
même
21ème qu'alfred
merci merci beaucoup de français
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
djibouti soit un type à chaumont 25
exactement toujours aussi spécial david
je me rappelle comme qu'il est arrivé il
n'avait que 18 ans j'étais dans cette
salle avec les journalistes de cette
conférence de presse qui avait été très
jeunes
filles
en live vous venez de suivre cette
conférence de presse qui a eu lieu où
ambiance détendue on lisait avec
sébastien autour de ceux autour de cette
conférence de presse à quelques blagues
échangés par dans sa lettre à la fille
on a l'impression qu'il avait quand même
remporté un titre de ligue des champions
oui c'est ça c'est très célébre est
évidemment cette promulgation de khiyam
bape et
ça me fait penser on pourra peut-être à
en parler un petit peu plus longuement
notamment avec les questions du chat
bien sûr si on nous en parle un petit
peu il ya ce côté on fait aujourd'hui la
prolongation de deux clients le bape est
un peu comme on fêtait par exemple
l'arrivée de lionel messi ou d'autres
bonne recrue au mercato dernier
voilà il ya ce côté en fait on fait tout
ça le p j'aimerais quand même en
maintenant fêter un peu plus ses titres
en gagner un petit peu plus et surtout
fêter enfin une ligue des champions à
peu de la même manière qu'ils peuvent
fêter ce genre de contrat aujourd'hui
donc alors je vais rêver c'est de
prendre vos commentaires dans le chat
parce que j'avais un commentaire tout à
l'heure alors j'ai essayé de retrouver
le nom de la personne jour les canadiens
qui disait ça devient le fcm bape est en
fête avec donc on met on met un joueur
au centre du projet est la céréale fils
a dit le meilleur joueur du monde oui
alors main sous un jour au centre du
projet ça n'est pas ce n'est pas
scandaleux ce n'est pas choquant il ya
beaucoup de clubs qui ont fait ça avec
un joueur qui sort un petit peu du lot
le barça l'a très bien fait le psg avait
un peu cette ambition au début avec avec
neymar l'a eue avec ibrahimovic et on a
vu que sportivement ça pouvait ça
pouvait donner quelque chose quand même
d'intéressant de cohérent là dessus je
pense qu'il n'y a pas un gars pas de
problème il ya un joueur qui sera un
petit peu au dessus du lot après il ya
une question un petit peu annexes au
delà du terrain et celle là était un
petit peu posé pendant la conférence de
presse c'est quel point est ce qu'il a
au delà du t1 au delà de son statut de
joueur
c'est pas non plus le directeur sportif
du psg mais à quel point est ce qui peut
peser dans les décisions dans le
changement de la direction sportif dans
le changement d'entraîneur peut être
dans le recrutement des joueurs à quel
point ce qui peut peser là dessus ça
c'est une grande question qui entoure le
psg actuellement il ya une réponse qui
était assez marquante c'était il a dit
il ya un an j'avais l'intimé conviction
que je devais rejoindre le real de
madrid le meilleur choix à l'époque
c'était celui-là et depuis d'autres
choses sont venues il a parlé du côté
sentimental d'être français que c'était
important pour lui il a dit aussi le
club va changer des choses sur le
sportif donc le sportif va changer on
essayait déjà ils ont essayé pour la
conférence de presse à savoir un peu qui
c'est qui visait mais on se doute que
leonardo doit quand même être un peu
visé dans cette affaire oui oui c'est
très clair leonardo donc c'est
maintenant elle sa fuite un petit peu
que il était quand même assez contesté
en interne qu'on n'était pas toujours
convaincu de comment ça se passait au
club quand il y avait ce côté un petit
peu un peu un peu disneyland quoi que
c'était un petit peu n'importe quoi
alors sur le paraître c'est très joli et
le mercato le dernier mercato maladie
incroyable prendre donna roumat le
meilleur joueur de l'euro prendre
lacheraf à kimi a appris à ces anneaux
net alors que c'était un des meilleurs
joueurs au monde à son poste nuno mendes
très prometteur mais si on n'en parle
même pas donc il y avait des choses qui
pouvait apparaître assez assez sexy en
tout cas sûre sur le papier sauf qu'on a
vu que il suffit pas il suffit pas de ça
que cette équipe a tourné absolument pas
rond c'est ce qu'on n'a pas me répéter
en boucle ces derniers mois
donc clairement il ya eu le même jour où
on a appris la prolongation de maps et
on a appris le départ dolana de leonardo
on a appris l'arrivée de jorge campos
apparemment ou qui quel que soit quel
que soit son nom donc jorge campos a
priori pour sunrise pardon mais
effectivement louise campost on rappelle
directeur sportif du côté de monaco de
lille qui a fait remporter un titre à
monaco et à lille on imagine que
problème maps et qui était au à monaco
quand luc angers caen wisques en poste
depuis des décennies était au club pour
lui c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
important oui c'est très important
effectivement alors musc enfin je crois
qu'il était plus à lille au moment du
titre mais c'est un peu c'est lui qui a
posé les pierres qui a montré un petit
peu le chemin à monaco et à lille qui a
fait que que de l'excellent travail et
qui forcément l'imaginent à une
connexion avec avec liam bape et de par
pas par leur passage commun à monaco est
la réussite commune surtout à monaco
c'est clair c'était quelque chose d'
acte est est ce que c'était acté est-ce
que c'était une condition pour que
mbappé prolonge sa hausse aura jamais
j'arrive vraiment peu quand même
sans doute et l'imaginé maintenance
doute que ma perf et des réponses assez
assez policé sur le côté je ne suis
qu'un joueur je suis là uniquement pour
jouer je ne vais pas faire plus de
choses que ça on imagine que maintenant
il va quand même avoir un certain point
au moins un droit de regard un côté
qu'est ce que tu en penses au moins est
ce que tu valider ce que tu ne valide
pas si jamais mis un entraîneur dont il
donc bape et ne veut absolument pas on a
du mal à imaginer que le psg va lui dire
non c'est pas notre problème tu feras
avec c'est tout on à charles baltet dans
les commentaires qui me dit qu'elle est
un mec bien qui n'a pas la grosse tête
et j'ai vu aussi chris kraus qui le dit
c'est vrai qu'il n'a pas la grosse tête
il al'air humble on l'a vu aujourd'hui
un espèce de détachement à la fois de
très sûr de lui et à la fois qu'il
essaye de montrer qu'il sait rester à sa
place on a dit oui voilà c'est toujours
l'image de clients de maple est
effectivement qu'il arrêtait un peu
écornée comme il le reconnaît lui-même
d'ailleurs en 2019 parce qu'il avait
demandé je cible plus de responsabilités
au psg où il y avait ce côté maintenant
c'est moi le patron c'est moi qui décide
qui était peut-être un petit peu un
petit peu excessif un peu un peu brutale
je dirais donc oui il a toujours cette
cette fraîcheur cette franchise sur
certains sujets
il est très cash il est vrai on sent
qu'ils parlent qui parle naturellement
avec son coeur même si aussi faire
attention à ce qu'il dit réfléchis très
bien on sent qu'on a affaire à quelqu'un
d'extrêmement extrêmement intelligent
évidemment sur l'aspect communication il
a très bien géré il est cash sur
l'aspect real madrid surtout lorsqu'il
parle du real madrid il parle avec une
grande honnêteté il reconnaît qu'il a
appelée florentino perez beaucoup de
joueurs et ce qui est vrai beaucoup plus
les questions en essayant d'éviter de
faire le moindre commentaire de faire
des trucs très très plat l'huile est
très vrai là dessus ça c'est quand même
plutôt plutôt agréable on a les gâteaux
dans les commentaires qui me dit quand
tout club bat le real seulement
économiquement
alors savais que c'était une bien
économiques entre ces deux clubs mais
venant du real madrid et de été et de
son historique des 20 dernières années
c'est assez paradoxal où on peut le dire
oui assez paradoxal et on peut penser
que ce n'est pas vraiment une affaire de
sous ça nasser al-khelaifi l'a dit et
alors tendance à le croire on a du mal à
penser que que le real madrid s'est dit
non c'est trop d'argent on ne souhaite
pas aller au dessus pas vraiment le
joueur du real madrid a à se faire là se
faire doubler là dessus maintenant je
pense que c'est c'est au delà seulement
de l'aspect financier c'est peut-être un
peu de la dimension économique mais la
dimension économique c'est pas que de
l'argent il ya aussi vraiment la notion
de pouvoir au centre sportif avant tout
peut-être que ma paye n'aurait pas le
même poids sportif au real madrid
maintenant j'ai quand même l'impression
que le bape et essaye de se garder la
porte ouverte pour le real madrid
autant son discours assez gentil envers
le real je pense qu'il est qu'il est
sincère et qu' il aime vraiment ce club
il ne l'a jamais caché et qui va pas se
mettre à cracher sur le réal du jour au
lendemain
maintenant il a signé que pour trois ans
plus dans un an peut très bien voir
encore des rumeurs de ba ps qui va
partir le real revient à la charge on
peut être certain il y aura des rumeurs
est ce que ça sera vrai ou pas on verra
mais c'est pas impossible pour autant
qu'un jour à l'avenir on voit me battais
joue au real madrid on appelle il n'a
que 23 ans effectivement c'est ce droit
de regard sur le sportif quand on en
parle et c'est quelque chose qui
l'emploie nba
yao basket aux états unis il y à des
clubs il ya des joueurs de clubs
ressources par un kobe bryant à l'époque
des lakers à lebron james à cleveland
qui avait un vrai droit de regard
quelque chose qui se fait là-bas ouais
tout à fait alors je connais pas tous
les sports toutes les ligues mais
effectivement pour le coup en basket en
nba c'est quelque chose d'assez
présentes pour présenter un petit peu
pour ceux qui ne savent savent pas trop
qui est par exemple lebron james on
parle d'un des meilleurs joueurs de
l'histoire aujourd'hui qui elle-même qui
est aujourd'hui savait presque 20 ans
qui joue qui ont choqué toujours un top
niveau part d'un joueur qu'on compare à
michael jordan dans l'histoire du basket
pour un petit peu et c'est surtout un
joueur qui a pris une décision bien au
delà du terrain c'est pas juste que il
fait tout sur déjà il fait tout sur le
terrain mais des points dépasse à
défendre tout ça mais qu'en dehors il va
peser sur la direction sportive qui a
pesé sur sur le recrutement qu'elles
joueraient ce qu'on prend à moi j'ai
envie de jouer avec lui j'ai envie de
jouer avec lui je me mets moi même
l'appeler lui dire mais s'il vient jour
bien jouer avec moi tu verras ça va être
super moi je veux ce coach là il ya un
poids extrêmement important qui est
accordée à lebron james dans quasiment
toutes les équipes où il évolue
aujourd'hui c'est le cas notamment aux
los angeles lakers on l'a bien vu ces
dernières années oui ça se rapproche un
petit peu de ce qu'on voit peut-être en
nba peut-être à moins grande échelle
parce que comme je le disais avant la
conférence de presse je pense que le
basket est un sport 1 peut-être le sport
collectif le plus individualisé dont on
peut y avoir plus ce côté joueurs on a
fait tout ils sont moins nombreux sur le
terrain déjà exactement et il ya aussi
plus ce côté peut-être est-ce que ce
joueur est compatible avec tel joueur
alors qu'en foot c'est compliqué de
difficilement recruter des défenseurs
centraux latéraux en se disant est ce
qui l'émeut bape est compatible est ce
que ça va faire sur terrain c'est
différent c'est pas le même sport c'est
pas du tout la même chose maintenant oui
j'ai l'impression que le bape et se
rapprochent de cette dimension de pas de
changement pouvoir mais en tout cas de
d'équilibrage des forces de joueurs qui
qui prend un poids sans commune mesure
avec ce qu'on l'a vu auparavant dans le
sportif de son club on à jean-pierre
voto qui vous dit aux cavs rhys davies
et demander s'il ya une relation de
cause à effet entre la prolongation de
la baie et le licenciement de
de leonardo qui n'est pas effectif fac
n'est pas en tout cas officielle pour
l'instant pas de pas de communiqué il ya
un juriste qui a quand même essayé de
lui demander quand il a dit alors niveau
sportif vous avez dit qu'il ya eu des
changements quelles sont ces moments là
et là on a eu droit à une magnifique
langue de bois de da serra la fille oui
totalement alors dire le nom de leonardo
là je pense que ça aurait été compliqué
parce que là sur laquelle langue de bois
de chaume de moi l'idée c'était
justement je pense que pose cette
question un petit peu plus subtil parce
qu'on sait très bien que leonardo va
partir d'essayer de comprendre à quel
point est-ce que la prolongation de ma
paie et le départ dollars nos plus
l'arrivée domus comme pose comme d'hab
et koné sont liés oui c'est clair
moynier bape et je sais plus exactement
ce qu'il a dit mais je crois qu'à un
moment donné il a reconnu que sur le
plan sportif quand il explique que sa
décision pourquoi est-ce qu'elle a
changé depuis un an je sais plus
exactement ce qu'il dit mais il a une
réponse assez assez honnête là dessus ou
en fait on comprend en substance que oui
il ya des choses qui sont actés il ya
des choses qui sont en train de bouger
au psg et c'est aussi en partie pour ça
que les sites de plongée les équipements
dont parle du sportif par exemple le
coach maintenant c'est les ccc la
question qui va se poser mauricio
pochettino qui est toujours en poste
actuellement mais qu'on sait qui sort
d'une saison difficile on parle déjà de
pas mal de noms pour le remplacer oui on
parle de beaucoup de noms notamment je
me souviens de joachim loew ont
abandonné 2 entendu content et ça semble
être la priorité c'est pas mal éloigner
ces derniers temps maintenant la
nouvelle priorité ça semble être ruben
amorim en tout cas c'est le journal le
parisien qui a annoncé sa rue de la
mairie de l'entraîneur très jeunes de 37
ans qui entraîne au sporting portugal
qui aurait des liens avec avec louise
compose donc ça pourrait expliquer
effectivement il ya un gros flou sur sur
cet entraîneur mais ça sera certainement
la prochaine la première grande décision
de me ce campus il faut réussir aussi à
tenir ce vestiaire avec un
entraîneur jeune c'est pas forcément
facile oui c'est ça et puis alors aux
biens amorim pour le coup si on en parle
ces expériences très très faible c'est
un entraîneur qui a commencé en fin
d'année 2010 9 début 2020 sont sa seule
expérience en ligue des champions
concrètement c'est d'être allé en 8e de
finale pour prendre 5 0 par manchester
city sait pas vraiment ce qu'ambitionne
le pga à l'avenir on est sur un
entraîneur qui n'a jamais coaché de
stars comme il y en a au psg et on sait
que c'est une dimension très importante
ça tous les entraîneurs récemment passé
l'ont reconnu m thomas stovell mais
mauricio pochettino aujourd'hui il faut
quand même un entraîneur qui est
peut-être une certaine poigne pour
insuffler quelque chose à son équipe qui
puisse vraiment
exprimer son autorité et en même temps
faut aussi un entraîneur qui soit
capable de gérer les stars de gérer les
égos de en fait de gérer ce groupe tout
simplement d'en faire quelque chose de
cohérent comme ancelotti le fait très
bien dans pas mal de clubs où il est
passé notamment madrid en ce moment donc
où il ya c'est vraiment le gros chantier
aujourd'hui sur l'entraîneur c'est de
trouver celui qui réunira toutes les
qualités qui pourra vraiment s'exprimer
au mieux au pg on a killing chapeau dans
les commentaires qui me disent porte
ivement si jamais il arrive à gagner une
ligue des champions avec le psg des
émotions serait largement amplifié que
de la gagner avec le real madrid c'est
aussi ce qu'il a dit l'aspect
sentimental comme beaucoup il est
français il veut rester en france ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui a l'air
très important pour lui oui bien sûr
aujourd'hui s'il remporte une ligue des
champions au psg ça ça sera extrêmement
fort parce que le psg j'ai pas taquiner
pas il est il est conçu maintenant
aujourd'hui pour gagner la ligue des
champions mais on a du mal encore à le
prendre au sérieux il ya trop d
élimination en huitièmes de finale et en
france alors chaque été ça me revient ça
revient petit peu sur le premier de la
première chose qu'on disait en sortant
de la conférence de presse côté le psg
ce qui célèbre c'est un peu les
prolongations de contrat les recrues et
c'est la réalité le pg célèbre célèbre
beaucoup ça mais en fait sur le terrain
ça se traduit pas le mercato dernier en
était la preuve sportivement ça a été un
échec total alors qu'on parlait d'une
réussite totale justement sur sur le
mercato donc aujourd'hui je veux gagner
cette ligue des champions le jour où il
va le faire ça sera fort ça sera comme
comme manchester city et gagnera sa
première ligue des champions après tous
ces efforts tout ce travail qui sera
enfin récompensé pour ba bê ça sera
entré dans l'histoire du psg entré un
peu plus dans l'histoire du foot
français est vraiment envoyer un message
à l'europe de je suis resté dans ce club
là et je lui ai fait gagner la ligue des
champions on à jean paul ii qui nous dit
nasser vient de se rattraper de la
défaite en ligue des champions alors
déjà cette défaite des champions face au
real de madrid c'était un peu le tournoi
semble être un peu en plus de tournant
les deux prétendants des maps et le
règne de la reine qui renverse le psg on
se dit là
c'est perdu effectivement car ses fans à
faire ce sera soirée rap aujourd'hui oui
c'est ça il ya un côté un petit peu un
petit peu revanche c'est sûr maintenant
j'ai envie de dire c'est marrant parce
que c'est exactement ce qu'on a vécu en
2017 avec la remonte à la face au barça
est derrière le psg qui prend neymar et
pour les résultats qu'on connaît c'est à
dire des résultats des résultat nul
décevant le psg n'a pas gagné la ligue
des champions comme ça je pense que le
barça était ok pour pour lâcher neymar
si en contrepartie de gagner la ligue
des champions c'est pas arrivé depuis
mais je pense que le real est ok pour
faire la passion de bap et si ça leur
permet de gagner la ligue des champions
ce samedi le psg enfin c'est bien vous
abandonnez de de gagner là dessus mais
ce qu'il va falloir c'est gagner sur le
terrain ça le psg ne l'a toujours pas
fait alors il ya des grands changements
des changements très intéressant le
départ de leonardo c'est quand même
extrêmement fort salle un risque de
bouleverser le psg on verra qui sera
l'entraîneur maintenant un show comme du
rebelle amorim par exemple ça serait un
choix extrêmement fort très surprenant
un entraîneur qui l'a quasiment aucune
expérience en ligue des champions qui a
37 ans et un an de plus que sergio ramos
ça serait ça serait assez incroyable
maintenant c'est ça qu'on va surveiller
est ce que le psg va enfin traduire
toutes ces prouesses j'irai en dehors du
terrain à réussir à les traduire sur le
terrain j'ai entendu aussi le nom d'un
autre entraîneur anciens horaires de le
de liga qui était en train de crier
entraîneur au portugal c'est sa joconde
c'est ça qui pourrait revenir en l'ayant
belge mais on en parle aussi alors son
entraîneur là pourquoi ces différents de
ruben amorim déjà plus expérience
évidemment même si en ligue des
champions il n'a pas non plus un grand
pedigree
c'est un entraîneur au style aussi assez
différent avec plus de poigne plus de
deux caractères tu étais un peu plus on
va dire sulfureux un peu plus nerveux
qui se rapproche peut-être sur ce côté
là un peu d'un an thaï aimerait par
exemple qu'on a vu récemment au au psg
qui est pas qui a pas ce côté assez
c'est détente on va dire pour de
pochettino par exemple qui est assez
tranquille acn qui est pas du genre à
vociférer a enflammé un match lorsqu'il
est lorsqu'il est sur le banc c'est
assez différent mais là encore une fois
on est sur un entraîneur qui a une
expérience assez relative en ligue des
champions
maintenant on verra ruben amorim sergio
conceiçao ça serait quand même des choix
assez surprenant et qui serait étonnant
quoi pour le pays on a jugé débord qui
nous dit maintenant il faudrait bosser
le respect de l'artiste l'institution
auprès des joueurs effectivement on en
parle depuis très longtemps le respect
de l'institution au psg arrivait à
fédérer ses joueurs et les faire tous
revenir pour voilà pour s'allier autour
d'un but commun oui alors après je pense
qu'il faut faire attention parfois avec
le terme institution qui est parfois
peut-être un petit peu galvaudé on parle
de respect des institutions on pense à
des grands clubs
certains clubs arrivent à faire
respecter leur institution et se font
parfois un petit peu marcher dessus
aussi ça arrive par des joueurs qui ne
veulent pas venir par des joueurs qui
peuvent faire un peu des caprices pour
pour partir pour prolonger pour ne pas
prolonger on l'a vu au barça par exemple
le cas messi qui était très compliquée à
gérer il ya le cadre des mails et
aujourd'hui qui est très complexe on ne
voit toujours au real madrid à chelsea à
liverpool il ya des cas toujours un
petit peu un petit peu compliqué mais on
a quand même la pression oui que le psg
pour beaucoup moins rond que que que
certains de ces clubs là en tout cas
qu'en interne ça va beaucoup moins bien
il ya beaucoup de choses qui suit sur le
fonctionnement en interne ce
fonctionnement des stars sur un
entraîneur qui n'arrive pas du tout à
s'imposer thomass to run ça il en
parlait beaucoup après qu'il soit parti
du psg oui jugé presque le pg un coach à
bhl et indirectement il critique est je
pense un petit peu leonardo qui vient
qui vient de partir donc il ya peut-être
enfin ce virage tant attendu maintenant
du côté du côté du péché du cul du psg
on peut parler aussi un peu du real
madrid qui vient de passer à côté des
maps et qui n'a pas eu l'air ligne
allende qui était l'autre grand
attaquant dont peut-être le club avait
besoin alors ils sont en finale de ligue
des champions ils ont une équipe qui
tourne quand même assez bien au final
ils ont gagné la liga mais le mercato va
pas forcément se passer comme il
l'aurait voulu non c'est assez assez
assez surprenant parce qu'en fait bape
et va rester au psg à lens va aller à
manchester city et lewandowski devrait
peut-être aller au barça donc est ce que
tu es un peu real madrid grand perdant
en tout cas pour l'instant le mercato
estival n'a même pas officiellement
ouvert ses portes donc il ya encore le
temps pour le pour le real madrid faut
aussi prendre le temps je pense
d'analyser la situation du real
aujourd'hui karim benzema ça va encore
très très bien ils tournent encore très
bien même s'il n'a pas dix ans devant
lui bien sûr il ya eu vraiment l'exclût
pas l'éclosion n'est plus dans la
confirmation de vinicius à ses côtés en
attaque mais aussi une équipe très
prometteuse on avait terminé tant en
défense qui a une saison parfois un
petit peu compliqué mais qui a montré de
très grandes choses sur la première
saison alors qu'il a à peine à peine 23
ans je pense surtout à eduardo cas
mavinga qui a vraiment fait un printemps
exceptionnel avec des entrées très
impactante en ligue des champions qui à
19 ans
ça le real madrid n'est pas en crise on
n'en est pas là du tout et encore une
fois il ya des victoires sur le mercato
il faut ensuite aussi des victoires sur
le terrain c'est plutôt là que ça va
jouer pour le real le real qui a très
peu recruté l'été dernier ça leur donne
plutôt raison ils sont champions
d'espagne sont en finale de ligue des
champions je pense pas qu'il faut non
plus tirer la sonnette d'alarmé pour le
real madrid merci beaucoup c'est bastien
d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui merci
à vous d'avoir été très nombreux à nous
suivre j'encourage ceux qui nous suivent
sur twitter et sur youtube à s'abonner
d'ailleurs à notre chaîne pour ne rater
aucun de nos de nos futurs live aim map
et continue sa tournée médiatique
puisqu'il sera ce soir au jt de tf1 pour
voilà pour expliquer son choix avant de
partir pas en vacances puisqu'il sera à
clairefontaine un comble pour les
prochains matchs qui vont se dérouler le
programme de figaro live à 16h50 vous
avez plus du football on va parler
politique et elisabeth bornes qui
tiendra un point presse pour les
premiers jours de son gouvernement 17h30
autres à marine le pen qui parlera des
législatives depuis marseille et 18
heures vous avez rendez vous bien
évidemment avec point de vue votre
émission quotidienne et moi je vous dis
à bientôt pour de nouveaux lives sur
figaro